comment vous allez aujourd'hui bien la
forme je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une vidéo un peu
particulière il ya quelques jours sans
mais différents réseaux sociaux
j'ai lancé une bouteille à la mer pour
essayer d'aider les entreprises tech
hardware française de la brillante je
pouvais l'idée c'est de les mettre en
avant pour vous les présenter et vous
donner des bonnes idées d'achat pour les
fêtes de fin d'année parce que oui c'est
une chaîne de textes si vous êtes là
c'est que vous aimez la taille comme ça
vous pourrez découvrir des innovations
françaises entreprises françaises plein
de produits que vous ne soupçonnez
peut-être pas donc vous avez pris on va
commencer j'ai tous là dessus j'ai tout
là j'arrive un peu pareil j'ai tout
là-dessus j'ai une grande liste avec
plein de boîtes dont je tiens à vous
parler et je pense qu'il y en a que vous
connaissez il y en a que vous ne
connaîtrez pas payant des belles
découvertes dans tous les cas toutes les
entreprises dont je vous parle je vous
mets des liens en bas dans la
description vous pouvez cliquer pour les
découvrir pour aller acheter leur
produit ne serait ce que pour aller voir
en savoir un peu plus je tiens à
préciser que ces entreprises qui ont été
sélectionnés ces entreprises qui m'ont
envoyé des emails à l'adresse que
j'avais donnée amour @ monsieur leur
point fr c'est une vidéo ponctuelles
peut-être on en fera d'autres
ultérieurement pour la toute première
vous la connaissez vous en ai parlé
plein de fois je même parti en trip avec
eux m'envoyer en l'air
cros cole cros cole qui est une
entreprise qui fabrique des smartphones
mais également des tablettes pour
l'outdoor résistants dans les conditions
extrêmes
leur modèle le plus haut de gamme grand
public c'est le trekkeur x4
j'ai testé à new york c'est vraiment un
très très bon produit super sympa pour
l'outdoor
donc si vous voulez un smartphone qui
très robuste pour aller vous balader
l'extérieur pour les faire de
l'alpinisme pour aller faire du
canyoning pour faire tout ce que vous
voulez et même si vous travaillez
pourquoi pas dans des métiers où vous
risquer d'abîmer votre smartphone
notamment le btp est bien celui à vous
pouvez le prendre
il ne craint rien il vous rendra de
grands services gros score une fois de
plus je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans
la description entreprises françaises
suivantes dont je vous ai parlé
également il ya quelques jours sur
l'audio s'est dit d'accord ce n'est pas
de diva corps d'yves accords font
des écouteurs des petits intra ça ce
sont les antipodes de jeu sorti une
vidéo il ya quelques jours de fugue je
vous mets le lien dans la description
ils sont vraiment extrêmement
intéressante et très bonne tenue bonne
qualité audio réduction bruit passive
très belle réussite de la part de divin
corps donc si vous voulez acheter
français s'ils voulaient des intra si
vous aimez c'est intra une fois de plus
à des tchèques et la vidéo parce qu'ils
sont franchement vachement cool
compatible avec siri avec google à 600
mhz alzonne beaucoup je trouve très très
bien une fois de plus le lien est en bas
dans la description on va continuer avec
notre entreprise dont je vous ai pas
encore parlé
c'est l'entreprise d'asthme j'avais
découvert ce produit avait gas est alors
sorti un tout nouveau produit
c'est le ba semis plus dans cette boîte
clap en fait le produit c'est celui là
si vous regardez comme ça vous n'avez
pas deviné ce que c'est d'ailleurs dit
le mot en banque commenté remettez la
pause et dites moi quel est ce produit
de base mis le bas semis plus ses traits
interpellant comme produit chez les
positionner sa se positionne comme ça en
fait plonger le micro cayla j'ai essayé
de ne pas trop toucher à votre avis à
quoi ça sert on met la pause allez-y que
mark et moi en commentaire ok on reprend
pas l'or en fait ce produit là et bien
et vous permet de ressentir la musique
que vous écoutez un truc un peu bizarre
mais vous allez voir on va illustrer il
se connecte en bluetooth directement
avec mon smartphone vous avez entendu ça
veut dire en fait là c'est assez dingue
donc je les connecter j'aime mettre de
la musique n'importe laquelle ils voient
comment ça marche
parce qu'on attendait en fait ça fait
comme une espèce de caisson de basses
qui va venir et on aime ça la sensation
quand vous écoutez
l'idée c'est comme quand vous êtes en
club c'est vraiment elle est l'image que
je vais avoir prêté en club où vous êtes
en concert et que vous avez les seube et
vous sentez les la vibration sur vous et
voilà vous l'avez directement sur votre
corps cassé ma roue donc en fait là
c'est fort je me sens vraiment ce moment
alors il ya plusieurs votes via un mode
comme ça je vais pouvoir entendre la
musique à notre mode où ça va plus le
feutré comme si on était en dehors d'une
boîte de nuit et qu'on entendait le son
un peu tout fait il ya notre mode on a
vraiment que le que l'un fera cette
sensation là donc c'est assez marrant
moi j'aime ça crie ça permet de
ressentir
je voudrais parce que le micro à côté
permet de ressentir la musique qu'on
écoute il faut aimer il faut accrocher
au système vous pouvez l'utiliser aussi
bien on écoute de musique vous pouvez
utiliser en regardant un film notamment
sur votre smartphone vous pouvez
l'utiliser en jouant un jeu vous le
branchez sur votre prise jack de votre
manette vous rechargez ici en micro usb
la techno mais je trouve assez rigolote
ça s'adresse vraiment personnes qui
veulent ressentir directement sur eux
avec dans l'idée pourquoi pas et en plus
ce qui est assez bien fichue dans leur
système c'est que vous avez plein de
petits accessoires pour écouter de la
musique pour du gaming pour regarder un
film
l'idée est très très cool une fois de
plus vous aimiez le lien des secrétions
je crois que ça coûte un petit peu moins
de 130 euros pour ceux qui veulent
ressentir la musique que tout sympa on
continue avec une boîte française qui
vous développe un conteur connectés je
passe il vous connaissez ces espèces de
gros compteur pour les réseaux sociaux
en europe de l'est marc à d'autres
usages
et quand vous prenez la bonne et
s'incrémente de 1 en un comme ça vous
voyez vous en êtes donc la boîte et
française c'est plutôt bien cocorico
vous avez donc des compteurs pour
réseaux sociaux notamment ici voyez
compteur pour instagram peut avoir des
compteurs personnalisables pour les
entreprises je passe ici pour voir votre
chiffre d'affaires augmenter très
coûteux saison ça rien pourquoi pas en
plus mire les exporte dans 85 pays et ya
plus de trente mille entreprises qui ont
adopté
plutôt sympa donc si vous voulez avoir
un compteur collectés pour votre boîte
vous voulez même l'avoir regardé la ce
qui est très sympa c'est les compteurs
qui sont personnalisables
vous pouvez avoir votre propre compteur
comme vous le souhaitez pour différents
usages vous le marque pour les
partenaires pour du webmarketing pour la
vente
enfin ce qui marche moins sympa j'aime
bien ces français une fois de plus le
lien est dans la description autre
entreprise française que vous connaissez
peut-être saynètes atmo de tapioca parti
regroupe le
ren entreprises françaises qui vous
donne des solutions pour la maison
connectée que ce soit de la station
météo du thermostat connecter pour la
sécurité des caméras vous avez plein de
produits que ce soit pour l'intérieur
l'extérieur notamment pour des questions
de sécurité sont des produits sont
disponibles dans la grande distribution
dans les magasins spécialisés ou si vous
voulez rendre votre maison encore plus
connectés plus intelligent et bien les
jeter un coup d'oeil du côté de cnet a
tenu une autre entreprise pour la maison
connectée c'est à vis de seine à vis de
seine à l'éden à vis de ce 1 1 800 à vis
de celle je suis désolé non excusez-moi
je prononce probablement très très mal
il développe des solutions pour la
maison connectée sous leur propre marque
mais ils le font également pour philips
et thomson donc vous pouvez venir voir
il ya plein plein plein de chance une
fois de plus je vais le lien en bas dans
la description vous avez notamment ici à
vis de seine à vis à vis tu sens je suis
désolé pour le prononcer chevaux
sérieusement c'est le kit de démarrage
ou vous y retrouver une prise vous avez
trouvé une caméra se retrouve à une
ampoule connectés compatibles avec
google assistants et amazon avec sa
machine folle idée plutôt sympa donc une
fois de plus si vous voyez votre maison
plus connectés plus intelligent que se
font au niveau des prises au niveau des
ampoules pour la sécurité lien dans la
description une autre entreprise que je
ne connaissais pas dans l'univers du pc
c'est bleu jours est-ce que vous
connaissiez vous le jour dit que le
manga en commentaire il fabrique des pc
des mini pc des stations de travail mais
également des accessoires que ce soit de
l'hymne tel de la mdc une reprise
toulousaine vous avez vraiment quelque
chose qui est extrêmement compact les
ordinateurs plus est vachement sympa
c'est super joli une autre entreprise
qui cette fois ci elle n'est pas
réellement une entreprise hardware tech
mais qui fabrique des petits étui pour
nourrir protéger vos produits ici
notamment vous avez un petit étui qui
vient protéger vos épaules
moi ce que j'aime bien avec l'atelier
gaston et bien c'est qu'en fait ils vont
récupérer des chutes de grandes marques
de luxe ou bien de chutes issues de
l'automobile fabrique des tubes pour
airpod jean paul cros il ya pas mal de
choses c'est assez sympa une fois de
plus vous aimiez le lien en bas dans la
description puis derrière il y avait une
idée en plus écoresponsable valorisation
des déchets autres entreprises se
trouvent très maline c'est octavio je
vous explique le principe imaginez chez
vous je sais pas si c'est le cas vous
avez un système hi fi vous avez des
enceintes que vous utilisez pour écouter
de la musique vous avez une chaîne hi-fi
et elle n'est pas connecté vous aimeriez
pouvoir la rendre plus intelligent que
vous aimeriez pouvoir la connecter sans
forcément la changer parce que vous
aimez le sont parce qu'elle est la
puissance avant de l'acheter parce
qu'elle marche très bien et bien
octavio vient justement vous rendre
service vous avez un petit boîtier vous
allez venir connecter directement à
votre enceinte
qui lui par contre va se connecter en
wifi à votre maison et va venir diffuser
vos services de streaming préféré que ce
soit 10h07 indal que ce soit spotify
amazon musique directement dans vos
enceintes dans notre chaîne hi fi sans
que vous ayez besoin de la changer ou
d'acheter une enceinte connectés ça
vient éviter de jeter ses vieux
appareils on peut toujours les faire
fonctionner en plus soutenu une
entreprise française
j'aime beaucoup une fois de plus le lien
est à manama des scripts autres
entreprises ces comics qui est un
accessoiriste gaming français donc si
vous êtes un gamer si vous voulez des
produits des accessoires pour le gaming
ou pour aller jeter un coup d'oeil sur
le site de comics vous avez des gaming
pc vous voyez gaming console clavier
casque écran fauteuil ban est ce
vraiment la complète donc plusieurs
collections les drakkars vous avez one
love takes gaming console ps4 switch
switch light xbox one audio et mobilité
également produit des arrivées ils ont
la licence lapins crétins soit plutôt
bien je vous laisserai jeter un petit
coup d'oeil si vous cherchez des
accessoires pour noël pour vous faire
plaisir
et bien vous pouvez aller jeter un coup
d'oeil sur le pied de guerre mais pour
la paix s 5
donc ça c'est très cool pour les gamer
je pense que vous avez de quoi faire ici
autant entreprises françaises c'est et
kodjo et kodjo qui vous permet
d'économiser sur votre facture
électrique à la maison c'est une fois de
plus un objet connecté un d'objets
intelligents qui vous permettra à savoir
exactement où est ce que donnait dans
votre consommation électrique david
application sur votre smartphone qui
vous dit combien vous avez consommé en
eau chaude votre réfrigérateur vos
plaques de cuisson qui vous donnera des
missions pour venir économiser c'est
plus malin ça et vite devenir gaspiller
je vois plutôt bien et puis ça permet
d'être conscient réellement de sa
consommation électrique
vous voyez par exemple que 1 degrés de
trop sur un radiateur verser 100 euros
par an prennent pas mal veille inutile
plus de 80 euros par an congélateur
livré plus de 30 % de votre consommation
dans l'idée de la maison connectée plus
intelligente on fait attention à soi
enfin attention au monde
le lien est dans la description pigeonne
la rencontre que je dis et kodjo depuis
tout à l'heure ses échos djoko voilà et
kodjo coopai kodock ne voulait pas vrai
boulet et kodjo qu'au bon par contre
c'est le vrai bon gars dans la
description pouvez y aller autres
produits pour la maison connectée qui
vous permet de prendre conscience de
votre consommation de la consommation
excessive et bien c'est hydro alors
hydra roach je sais pas si vous
connaissez
c'est un pommeau de douche connectés et
intelligent j à la maison je le teste
vous explique le principe vous avez donc
votre pommeau de douche quand vous
l'allumez et bien vous avez lu
hier verte ça vous indique que vous êtes
dans le bon peut vous toucher pas de
problème et en fonction du temps qu'ils
passent surtout de l'eau que vous allez
utiliser bien il va changer de couleur
jusqu'à arriver à la couleur rouge pour
vous dire elle avoue déconner il est
temps d'arrêter vous consommez beaucoup
trop l'idée c'est pas de vous
culpabiliser l'idée c'est de nous
responsabiliser tous nous rendre compte
de la consommation qu'on va pouvoir
avoir en eau vous avez ensuite ou dans
votre application qui vous montre ce que
vous avez économisé en faisant attention
sur vos dernière douche j'utilise depuis
pas très très longtemps donc que j'ai
pas beaucoup beaucoup de stats
l'idée est vraiment bonne vous avez à
côté aussi de gamification votre peau me
douche peut stocker jusqu'à 200 douche
en interne et en plus un peu maudit
connectés qui fonctionne sans batterie
que demander de mieux autre produit qui
est super sympa dont je vous parlerai un
peu plus tard parce que je les tests
sont des lunettes d'être julbo julbo une
entreprise qui vient du jura sont des
lunes et yala basque avec des lunettes
pour l'outdoor pour le sport et là ils
ont fait des leaders qui sont juste
génial ce sont les évadés one et les
ehpad watts sont des lunettes connectés
réalité augmentée lorsque vous faites du
sport vous avez des infos directement
dans votre lunette ici sans que ça vous
gêne vous voyez ça fichiers votre
pourcentage de batterie bien évidemment
votre allure instantané la durée de
l'activité distance parcourue dénivelé
positif cumulé vitesse instantanée et
vitesse moyenne en plus vous avez une
application dans lequel vous voulez tout
monitorer je vous invite à aller jeter
un coup d'oeil sur le site de jules bof
c'est très malin ça faisait une petite
caméra toft vous passez votre main comme
ça devant en faisant du vélo en courant
même pourquoi pas ça vous change notre
affichage pour venir naviguer comme ça
très facilement si c'est pour vous que
vous faites du vélo que vous faites de
la course à pied que vous voulez des
lunettes fabriquées par un lunettier pas
plus important avec une entreprise
française qui fabrique toute la partie
connectés et bien vous pouvez y aller
parce que c'est vachement bien sûr
trouvant pas d'ici quelques bonnes
journées de ses lunettes là parce
qu'elles sont vraiment super bien
autre entreprise pour ceux qui veulent
une borne d'arcade entreprises
françaises flex harkat qui fabrique ses
propres bandes d'arcade
aujourd'hui nos studios à paris une
borne d'arcade monsieur ressasser rigolo
vous avez plein de jeux au catalogue si
vous voulez une borne d'arcade à la
maison pour faire complètement
personnalisé avec énormément de jeu
catalogue est bien allé voir à ce que
fait que sa requête est super bien
ils font tout eux-mêmes vous ai mis le
lien en bas dans la description autre
entreprise française qui est connu dans
le domaine de la santé c'est hugo qui ai
connu beaucoup pour ses pansements en
trop mais hugo une partie tex et urgo
tech et là il vous propose
du vasco qui s'appelle u're gonna ici
c'est un bandeau de sommeil connectés
qui vous permet d'entraîner votre
cerveau le jour pour mieux dormir la
nuit c'est un programme d'entraînement
cérébral
si vous avez du mal à vous endormir que
vous vous réveillez la nuit que
franchement le soldat gay ou basse et
des fois un petit peu difficile et bien
là vous avez un truc qui est vachement
sympa chez hugo night vous avez une
application vous permet mesure et
visualiser vous entraînez mieux dormir
ça c'est plutôt sympa donc si vous êtes
sujet avoir des problèmes
d'endormissement ou vous réveiller la
nuit vous dormez très très mal eh bien
ça peut être une solution vraiment
intéressante pour vous invite à venir la
découvrir une fois plus c'est une
innovation française le lien dans la
description aux entreprises françaises
c'est terraillon terrillon terraillon
carayon qui vous propose des accessoires
connecter pour la maison sommeil pèse
personne connectée de balance de cuisine
comme ça c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins bon truc vous avez dreamer qui
autre solution de sommeil qui nous
n'avons pas une durant vos nuits on a
également une balance impédancemètre
connecter en wifi entreprises c'est
hizzi avec easy on reste dans l'idée de
la maison connectée mais cette fois ci
côté chauffage c'est un boîtier connecté
qui vous permet de piloter vos
radiateurs à distance alors il fabrique
bien plus qu'en boîtier connecté
je vous laisserai aller jeter un petit
coup d'oeil si ça peut vous intéressez
vous avez effectivement un contrôleur
pilotes ils ont également des sèche
serviettes complètement connecté
l'idée de venir connecter votre
chauffage si vous laissez de réduire vos
dépenses énergétiques
lorsque vous n'êtes pas là bas vous
venez chauffée à minima vous pouvez
programmer pas mal de choses en fonction
de l'heure à laquelle vous allez arriver
pour que quand vous arriviez et bien la
maison soit chaude en plus labellisé
french tech pour qui tu veux être plus
vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description aux entreprises françaises
qui est en train de se développer qu'à
un projet sur lui je vous mets le lien
dans la description ces french
acoustique qui fabrique une enceinte
connectés c'est la proton c'est
l'enceinte made in france alors là il
vous explique un petit peu tout le
projet vous invite à les jeter un petit
coup d'oeil parce que leur projet se
termine bientôt sur lui les peas ont
besoin d'un petit coup de main encore
lent simple n'est pas tout de suite
disponible si vous voulez les soutenir
et bien vous pouvez le faire sont des
passionnés qui fabrique ce produit qui
en avait qu'une cocquempot tg recyclé et
recyclable surtout travaille vraiment
faire un produit qui est super sympa et
coresponsable fabriqués en france et je
termine avec une entreprise vous allez
rien leur acheter qui fabrique le
premier moteur photovoltaïque autonome
vous avez un panneau photovoltaïque qui
va venir capter la lumière du soleil qui
va pouvoir lancer un moteur mais qui ne
va pas stocker vous n'avez pas de
batterie ne produit pas d'électricité
mais il convertit l'énergie solaire en
énergie mécanique
c'est un vrai sens à que ce soit pour
des fondations humanitaires des
associations des ong des collectivités
il vous montre agriculteur éleveur de
l'aquaculture dans l'architecturé ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'usagers le projet
est vraiment sympa il est très louable
il ya plein de belles choses à faire
avec on vous invite à venir les
découvrir
voilà pour cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle
vous aura fait découvrir beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises
une fois de plus voyez on a quand même
beaucoup de talent chez nous là je vous
montre quelques entreprises
sélectionnées mais il y en a énormément
il faudrait plusieurs vidéos pour
pouvoir tout tout tout vous les
présenter donc si vous aimez un des
produits que vous est présenté n'hésitez
pas allez les découvrir et pourquoi pas
acheter leurs produits pour venir
soutenir l'entreprise française tech
hardware sur ce je vous embrasse
beaucoup de gros bisous et à très
bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]
oui